هذه المره والان الى العاصمه الكوريه
الجنوبيه سيول ومن هناك مراسله صباح
العربيه اشواق العتوله يسعد هالصباح يا
اشواق دبي تناديك صباح العربيه يناديك في
ناس عم تسال انتقلت خلاص رسميا الى كوريا
الجنوبيه
اهلا صباح الخير نادين
صباح العربيه والله انا يعني ما عندي
مشكله اني انتقل لناس هون
ان شاء الله الرساله
انا حاليا موجوده في قلب العاصمه امام احد
اشهر البوابات التاريخيه والكنز الوطني
الاول في كوريا الجنوبيه بالمناسبه طبعا
انا اطل معكم اليوم هناك زياره خاصه
تشهدها سوريا الجنوبيه والعاصمه ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان وطبعا الزملاء
سيقومون بالتغطيات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
انا فقط
ولي العهد بس كمان نشير الى معلومه انا
قراتها بس مش متاكده اذا هي صحيحه تقول
انه الجاليه السعوديه هي اكبر جاليه عربيه
موجوده في كوريا الجنوبيه بالتحديد
انا ما عندي ارقام او اطفائيات وشير بس هو
فعلا من تواجد دائما وزيارته هناك كثير من
السعوديين المبتعثين المقيمين الاطباء
كذلك همم يعني في تواجد سعودي شبابي كبير
موجود
بحكم الثقافه بحكم التطور بحكم العلاقات
والتبادل الثقافي والتعليمي بين البلديه
طبعا هناك العديد من التعاونات وخاصه على
الصعيد الثقافي والفني همم كوريا خلال
الشهور الماضيه وقعت الكثير من هذه
الاتفاقيات وفي نشاط طبعا فني واحتفالات
كبيره تشهدها السعوديه خاصه في موسم
الرياضه هناك العديد من الحفلات الكوريه
الفنيه عشان طبعا حاليا ااه على حظنا
قاعده
طبعا مراسم اللي هو الفراش الفلسطيني بهذه
البواره انا الان اتواجد معكم من قلب
العاصمه مثل ما قلت لك احد همم البوابات
الاربعه الاساسيه في همم سوريا
طبعا همم
يعني اسناني
عم نسمعك اشواق كانه راح يبلش العرض اه
بلش
ههه
الذي يقام بشكل يومي امام هذه البوابه
التاريخيه التي بنيت عام 1395 في عهد
سلاله دوسون ويعني عصرت كل التطورات التي
شهدتها العاصمه سعود على مدار همم العثور
طبعا هي تمثل كنز وطني وكانت بالسابق همم
تحمي همم طبعا العاصمه سول من همم من
الخارج هذا الحراس هم اللي يمثلون الطقوس
العسكريه التي كانت تتم خلال العصور لحد
الان جميل انها محتفظه بهذا العادات درس
يعني همم تحتفظ بها خاصه للسياحه
المواطنين نفسهم الكوريين نحن طبعا
موجودين في منطقه جداويه ايضا اقتصاديه
والسياحيه همم اسم البوابه طبعا هو اسمهم
ليمون يعني طبعا بوابه الاحتفالات الضخمه
طبعا في احتفال ضخمه ههه
خالتي كنت حابه امشيكم من داخل عشان نشوف
الجهتين المنطقه التي اتوقع حاليا راح
يكون صعب ااه هناك العديد من المباني
الضخمه حوالينا في هالمكان هناك ايضا
العديد من الاسواق التي تعد هي الاكبر
والاقدم في سوريا الجنوبيه همم طبعا احن
انت قاعده تشاهدين معي اكيد عملنا بنشوف
عيد اه كامله اشواقي احنا الكلمه كلها لك
الله يسعدك
تسمى ايضا باسم غير
وهو ايضا يعتبر السوق تجاري تقليدي كبير
جدا في سوريا
الذي كل عام ايضا يوجد حوالينا
الشارع هل هو نفسه استوحه منه اغنيه جانجا
اللي هي الكوريه الجنوبيه اقتحمت وقتها
العالم
لا لا طبعا غير اسامي كلها تاريخيه ههه
اسم المنطقه والشارع الاخر اسمهم اليوم
[ضحك]
يعني طولتي الغيبه
الله عندك ناديه طيب ماشي شكرا